mes hommes à disparaît d'après mes
informations il est dans la prison
secrète d'hadès les gens qui étaient à
l'origine du tombeau ont subi un échec
mais revient en force
celui qui entre dans son jeu mais c'est
aussi simple sympa bienvenue à hadeth il
a besoin de nous
après tout ce temps derrière un bureau
est la peur que tu sois rouillé soupe
aux lentilles d'urso c'est quoi cet
endroit le royaume des morts
les animaux du zoo représente beaucoup
d'argent chacun détient des informations
qui se monnaient des millions de dollars
hors de ses murs je sais absolument tout
sur mes animaux jusqu'à le gardien du
zoo y a pas hésité à l'on cherchait peut
pas lancer comme ça on manque d'infos
sur le lieu sur leurs équipements au
tombeau c'est bien ce que tu as fait
j'ai eu de la chance
c'est une mission difficile pour nous
tous certes luc échouant disparu cherche
du boulot dur aux âmes
laisse-moi 24 heures et je trouve ça
écoute passer maintenant tu vas me dire
tout ce que tu sais
je savais que tu viendrait me chercher
l'attirer ici n'est pas sans danger
tu ne connais pas la configuration est
une peut compter sur personne
une présent fermés au monde sans témoin
il ya toujours une frey toujours
[Musique]
que la fête commence système de passes
et c'est trop tard
et voici c'est bon d'être de retour tu
veux peut se voir à quel point
[Musique]